la circulaire des yeux on nous dit opter
pour isme avec des petits paiements
c'est pour être de petits paiements ce
sont de petits paiements indus dollars
pour un duo laveuse sécheuse 16 $ pour
un frigo mais on est jeune on s'était
annoncée à seulement 18 dollars 18
dollars c'est par semaine pour une
location de 156 semaines au bout de ses
156 semaines
l'atterrissage enfin à vous mais vous
sera coûté 2008 108 dollars et savez
vous combien le même téléviseur se vend
ailleurs 605 $ on peut même le trouver à
498 $ ce qui veut dire que vous paierez
votre terrine quatre à cinq fois plus
cher chez vision morale de l'histoire
faites donc comme la marmotte laisser
passer l'hiver avancer vos sous et
pénible oui cher cette télé avant le
retour du sport